you know with everyone shopping online
during covid amazon is experiencing
record sales growth and they announced
that they're hiring
100 000 new employees well
this has led to other opportunities for
other businesses as well
check it out amazon is hiring 100 000
employees to try to keep up with demand
hi i'm jake tyrell ceo and founder of
porch hoppers
i've been stealing amazon packages off
of porches for over
seven years now more packages means more
work for me
and i'm swamped the good news is i'm
higher
if you're a sleazeball package stealing
could be for you
all you need is no moral compass and the
ability to outrun the average
stay-at-home mom
plus you're your own boss unless you
count me jake terrell
your boss with porch hoppers every
morning is like
christmas morning i got generic viagra
i got barbie's dream house i got a
mohair sweater
i think i'm allergic to mohair if you'd
like to interview for a position at
porch hoppers
meet me in the alley behind the quiznos
on van owen
no cops